I'm so happy to introduce Joe DeRosa
everyone this is Joe DeRosa Joe is one
of our wonderful writers here at the
peat Home Show he's also one of my best
friends in the world and we've also been
doing stand-up together for a very long
time we've been doing this segment I
guess we wouldn't have even called it a
segment back in the day a bit ya routine
we did a routine we started in
vaudeville and would do routines on
empty rail cars for hopeless and this is
actually something we've done many times
over the years through New York and LA
and it's basically about the product I
can't believe it's not butter do you
guys remember let's take a look at that
yeah sure there it is
one guy like what's that you say I can't
believe it's not butter a popular
product and one of our favorite products
to make fun of cuz it's the only thing
you see out there that the name of the
product is like a snippet of a
conversation you'd have about the
product you know I mean you're a
breakfast you're eating you're like huh
that's not butter what's that I I
honestly can't believe it's not butter
and they're like perfect and they put it
on the carton and that's the product
right yeah so we we always thought that
they should have released more products
that you know continued the conversation
you know by their names or whatever so
like like this one
really this isn't butter that's that's
weird it tastes like butter like a lot
we're doing it
yeah we're doing with it oh we imagine
the next one to be I'm kidding come on
bro
if this isn't butter just level with me
right now before I go to work I can't be
thinking about this all day
here's a good one seriously I'm not
gonna round here you need to tell me
clearly and directly what the this is
what do you think this is a game fine
it's not butter then what is it
very long that is a long one very long
for the shopping list next one is uh you
know I know what it is I do I figured it
out come on stop being a dick and just
tell me I wouldn't do this to you see it
has it has long pause on that stage
direction here's wine oh oh oh oh two
can play at this game
so I'm not eating butter okay well guess
what the stuff I fed you wasn't bacon
and finally this is the last one you
it's clearly butter spray
we did it show you running